[Music]
all right welcome to hey babe Sal
couldn't make it again this week but
don't worry he's coming back soon he'll
be back next week but instead of just
not doing the episode and mailing it in
I said who can I get that will equal Sal
yes
he's a big man but he's dead he's he's
dead weight anyway he was holding you
back Chris this is good Mark no I'm here
in Sam Morrow we might be drunk I like
the end of the gate you said instead of
not doing an episode you're lowering the
bar already yeah you go to the gate
you're like we could have not done one
yeah we could have not done one but
instead we went right above that and we
got Sammy and Mark baby the freshly uh
married Mark and the freshly and the
currently depressed Sam
hey we're both depressed I'm [ __ ]
I know I couldn't admit we had family
stuff I couldn't make it but I sent him
a gift well really sent him again let me
just say this
there it is
that was a weak married man
the Mark I knew like two months ago he
would have been farting much stronger
Chipotle and I could tell it was about
to unload so yeah that's a marriage fart
right there yeah I love it man that
wedding we we got so I got so [ __ ] up
Wednesday night
was it on Bodega Camp yeah
cat whiskey Straight White Whiskey go to
Bodega cap.com is it Bodega
catwhiskey.com Bodega catwhiskey.com
best ride in the game baby that's what I
like it you'll hit your wife yes
you'll have a conversation with her that
much needed one no that's even worse
yeah you'll ice her yeah
we got wasted uh I end up at a casino
with stav and Ari shaffir and all I
remember is we're we're in line at this
gas station stop led us to a gas station
he seems like it he looks like an
employee of a gas station
we're getting Fried Chicken Fried uh you
soft shell crab fried oysters just fried
from a gas station yeah
real Gamble
we're wasted and uh we're in line and
some some guy's just staring at the
three of us we're just glazed over and
he goes I know who you are when you hear
that you're like I'm [ __ ] wrecked
it's dicey then we're just stuffing our
face in our hotel lobby chug just
feeling disgusting and uh and I'm so
wasted at one point I just go man
imagine eating this [ __ ] sober and stop
goes I'm completely sober what
stop wasn't drunk he's sober he's like
getting healthy well yeah because he
said I know he went to Baltimore uh for
the summer to go to like a fat camp or
something like that his brother's a
trainer so
[Music]
far
yeah I thought I thought that uh but but
it's good he's losing weight then yeah
he looks looks I just told a story about
him picking out in a hotel lobby and
you're and you're saying this is good
once a week once a week in in everything
in moderation that's what I was thinking
moderation moderation I am yeah man I um
I wanted to go I've still never been to
New Orleans I got to get to that I'm
supposed to be there in January but me
too when are you there oh January 15th
or something dude I might be there what
are you there oh holy [ __ ] hold on I'll
tell you what I'm doing your whole trip
what are you doing down there Joy
theater uh I think that's the theater
I'm doing so we might not be wait hold
on I'll be there you ready for this
January 12th at the Civic Theater oh
how's that one it's good good Joy's
better though huh Joey's a little more
fun
I'm playing it next week Civic or joy
joy so is Civic a [ __ ] one to do
let's be honest it's a real spot that's
what they do the half hours for Comedy
Central yeah but I should have probably
[ __ ] so when are you there I think the
15th I think it's a Wednesday close no
start in the theater tour in in uh New
Orleans
the theaters are the way to go now man
the comedy clubs are fun you gotta work
out in a club you can't really work out
in the theater so you go to Club to work
on [ __ ] then you theater present it
here's my thing here's we were talking
about I was talking about this the other
day it's you know it used to be the
progression of comics you know you do
this you do the comedy club then you do
the theater then the bigger theater and
then one day the arena but you know with
the way the economy is right now it's
like one of those like things you would
never you almost have to think a little
outside the box now like I would never
at the end of a car lease buy the car
outright because it just seems like a
stupid investment but in today's economy
with car prices the way they are it's
like you should buy your car at the end
of the lease because it's probably it's
probably it's holding so much more value
same thing with like theaters you know
people like oh I don't know how to
charge my fans at theater price with
this kind of no [ __ ] money I'm like
maybe I'll just do the comedy club
that's just me trying to tell you my
tickets are slowing down
well you heard that old Depression era
thing like in a depression the only
things that go up are alcohol and
entertainment interests us yeah from
Sylveon The Sopranos yes yeah there you
go Silvio explain what what what things
are Recession Proof yeah what we do in
some forms of entertainment yeah yeah
clip it uh no the clubs are fun though
to work out in and like to build like I
did have you ever done Blue Room in
Springfield Missouri I was there last
night sure Great Clip oh the guy yeah I
saw that clip well dude the owner's a
character he's like completely he's nuts
he's not he's not oh yeah because you
just did Justin Smith's special there
right I filmed a special there and I had
saying I need to bring you out so my
girls would get mad at me so I had to go
to the strip club with them I've done
that you eat the steak he's what yeah
yeah they're known for a good steak it
wasn't good it tasted like a like
nothing I think I'm saying to me like
you know where to get the best steak is
is a strip club I'm like that's how you
know your Town's not known for good
steak yeah yeah they're not saying that
[ __ ] in Omaha no dude what but you know
what I went to Tampa once the best
salmon I've ever had in my life was at a
strip club really stupid it was
unbelievable
smelled the same yeah but I'll tell you
best soft shell crab New Orleans gas
station
did you have diarrhea did you seriously
like were you was your stomach a little
[ __ ] the next day from that yeah oh my
I was dying dude yeah I was dead we I
stopped and I got IV drips uh in our
hotel room was this before his wedding
or after that oh the night before but I
felt okay going in after the drip we had
a great uh we had a character we took a
New Orleans guy giving us that drip this
guy's a nurse and he's just he's just
got that draw that New Orleans oh uh let
me put some gay porn in the RV drip here
I don't know what that means but I
[ __ ] love this guy oh yeah it's a fun
town and I this is how you got these
jerk off comedy friends one guy texted
me I'm in an Uber hold on don't do the
ceremony yet I'm like what the [ __ ] yeah
wait for you hold on future wife this
guy is hungover who was it uh Andrew
Youngblood oh my God yeah I'm in an Uber
hold off on the ceremony was it so it
was all pretty much mostly Comics how
many non-comics made the wedding well I
think it was about 150 people there and
I'd say 50 were Comics okay 60. 50. then
you got Aunts Uncles Brothers
everybody's kids you know
I um yeah man I uh I are you guys
watching the World Cup do you care about
soccer I just watched like 10 minutes of
it dude Saudi Arabia just beat Argentina
it's the biggest upset in World Cup
history really yeah Saudi Arabia just
it's almost as upset as the women in
Saudi Arabia
I like it
yeah those uh we're the new Jokers yeah
those Sonny Ravens can kick rocks or
throw them all right
yeah man they're [ __ ] Argentina big
loss and uh yeah man are you into soccer
no but I just like watching the World
Cup I should I want to get into it I
just know I need someone to just like
take me through it well these game the
game start at six a.m so I was up with
my kids getting my kids ready for the
bus and I was like Saudi Arabia Saudi
Arabia versus
um Saudi Arabia Argentina I was like oh
Argentina's probably beating the [ __ ]
out of them yeah and then the Saudi
Arabians man they somehow won and uh
yeah biggest uh they say the biggest um
slave population ever in history in
Saudi Arabia I believe it there you go
well that's the thing that's why they're
that's the name of their team they're
the foreign
[Laughter]
yeah yeah dude that was a great special
the anti-Semitism is helping him I think
it's like it's all in the algorithm you
know
yeah no it is well I said no seriously
that he timed that perfectly yeah just
like the same way like what Rodney
Dangerfield well you know when his he
became famous because I get no respect
but at that time when he became famous
Godfather was out and it was the biggest
movie and that's all about respect so he
was the anti guy so that's what oh it's
all about anti-Semitism Ari comes in
says I'm the semi baby well you can tell
it is getting bad because uh I got
written up recently in an article as uh
openly Jewish
they call me openly which I've never
heard that term in my life that's
literally like I've never said to a
person that was Jewish and they and they
said uh who else knows right
right no you're just Jewish I've never
yeah not even here openly gay anymore
because there's more tolerance for for
gay people well you can't even be well
just be engaged isn't even enough
anymore you have to just you're gonna
step it up you have to come out of the
closet as like gay and then what else
what are the other letters that
non-binary just being gay ain't enough
be speaking again you can't um if if
you're in Qatar and you wear the rainbow
flag shirt a journalist just got thrown
out of the stadium got put in prison you
cannot and the players if you were an
lgbtq armband and Qatar you can get
penalized and you can be thrown in
prison and they say why people are the
worst yeah you don't know they have uh
bad gay laws there yeah
you can't do it but then [ __ ] but then
is that the pronunciation Qatar what is
the actual pronounce I think it's Qatar
guitar sounds like a Spanish infinitive
Qatar really did you guys see how people
are staying there in these tents yeah
Andrew Schultz is there Andrew Schultz
is going to guitar is that his podcast
Studio yeah there's Alex there's there's
Alex media being thrown off a roof
that looks like you're staying at a
[ __ ] hotel in Springfield Missouri
that's what that looks like actually the
hotel is nice then you think it's safer
to be gained Qatar Springfield Missouri
look at this piece of [ __ ] it's like a
fire Fest oh yeah they have a gender uh
bathrooms you think they go
gender-neutral bathrooms and guitar they
just no no I think the women [ __ ] on the
floor
love it
um that's what it is I wonder if the
women could you wear because if you go
out you can't walk around the streets
and guitar with your hair out like
vanity would get beheaded gorgeous
blonde hair tell them to tie it up but
they're going to tie her up and they're
called the morality police which is
hilarious interesting if anyone should
care about hair it should be balding
people yeah those are the people who
should be upset by hair I like it yeah
that's offensive I'm thinking thankfully
my dad is 75 years old doesn't even have
a receding hairline it's on my mom's
side yeah like did you use it on the
mom's side yeah yeah my mom's a balding
Pig
my mom's beautiful she's got beautiful
red hair I love my mom shut up
all right my mom's got beautiful fire
engine red hair oh don't go to Saudi
Arabia with that Ginger lady I know
tackled not gonna make it what are you
guys doing for turkey day anything big
Thanksgiving there's families are you
going to New Orleans yeah you go back to
you know my brother moved away with he
has two girls two kids and they're like
a big part of the family and they moved
to Wisconsin ooh because his wife's a
doctor and she got some gig over there
so my mom's uh just in a bad way so
she's like please come back so I gotta
go back so you gotta go but you but it's
good better to have Thanksgiving in New
Orleans and Wisconsin oh for sure yeah
where in Wisconsin is he Madison oh oh
there you go shopping tickets to Daniel
Simonson last week I love Daniel
Simonson
Norwegian freak so you ever go to the
bank
that's my Simonson if you guys don't
know Daniel Simonson uh uh look him up
he's a fantastic comic this book I want
to bring this up this is my daughter's
somebody got my daughter this this is a
children's book called Brenda's Brenda's
Beaver needs a barber and it's literally
about shaving a beaver and it's all
[ __ ] it's all [ __ ] jokes really yeah
the whole thing and uh do they know it's
[ __ ] jokes
a child the writer
enough [ __ ] talk for the night yeah but
is she going for the joke yeah no my
well no because she this whole book is
about like shaving the beaver shaving
the beaver and then my kid is innocent
she was running around because my uh my
girl gave my stepson a haircut the other
day and my and uh uh my daughter says to
my my girl she was like um she was like
uh mom you should shave your beaver with
that like Brenda I was like nice nice
I'm gonna make a book called choking the
chicken yeah
she wrote a follow-up to this called a
Brenda's Beaver stinks
uh
yeah you can't drink any beer at the
World Cup too mine what my thing about
bringing this up is is is when we talk
about because it's going on yeah well it
just feels like you know I'm just
sometimes I get [ __ ] mad when I'm
like you know you [ __ ] on you people
[ __ ] on America yeah they live in Qatar
then I didn't drink beer you can't be
gay you can't be a woman you hear that
Brittany grinder you got what you
deserved
[Music]
[Applause]
New Orleans Brittany grindier
unfortunately won't be there I love
Brittany grinder I uh I love Brittany
grinder too
oh in Italy they were throwing banana
peels on the field it's like what come
on come on we would never do that well
athletes cramp up it's for the potassium
right oh yes I thought it was a kind
gesture from that situation yeah that's
what it is and then if they slip that's
comedy gold oh Bang
Yeah so by the way I I want to just make
an announcement to the hey babe fans I
will not eat a ounce of turkey on
Thursday so don't tag me in pictures of
it if you see me on the streets of
Staten Island don't even [ __ ] mention
because vegan there's turkeys no there's
turkey turkeys wild turkeys live in my
neighborhood no Chris you'll be driving
down like the Boulevard in Staten Island
there's like legitimate wild turkeys
everywhere and when you live around
turkeys first of all what turkeys do is
the reason why they they congregate
around Deer they eat the deer [ __ ] and
when you see them they are disgusting
turkeys turkeys aren't disgusting right
eating [ __ ] they'll go like literally
walk up to my door
like and if you go out the window if you
go they'll go back kind of like the guys
at the bars in Staten Island
[Laughter]
it does sound like a Staten Island guys
would call gays couple of wild turkeys
I only not eat turkey I swear to God it
just what do you eat then on things I'm
gonna probably eat my mom bakes these
awesome biscuits so I'm gonna eat her
I'm gonna eat her biscuits I'll eat like
the the vegetables some mashed potatoes
and I'm genuinely thinking about just
literally going to like a Dominican
Bodega and just getting a rotisserie
chicken and just showing up I love my
aunt's house with a chicken because I'm
like I can't stomach the idea of turkey
if you lived around turkeys it's it dude
it's gross that's interesting it's
[ __ ] Disturbed the most disgusting
animals you've had [ __ ] send them to
Qatar well you can't watch any animals
you can't watch any animal eat because
it's it's all gross everything's growing
like chickens are in these little coops
oh yeah they're the cows are I know
that's what some people have said
they're like well whatever you saw the
way chickens lived and cows have been
like yeah but I don't dude they don't
live wildly around my chairs they live
wildly around Staten Island because
they're Republican turkeys we should
send the hobos out there that are in my
neighborhood to Staten Island and they
can [ __ ] eat those turkeys that's
what it is yeah get the hobos out there
yeah let them eat them they're dying for
a sandwich you're elected me turkey mugs
Mark's plan is a politician we gotta get
these hobos to Staten Island yeah yes
yeah I'm on the island
tickets don't cost too much to go over
the bridge [ __ ] 14 send them on the
ferry yeah yeah the Garbage barge yeah
yeah garbage March Avatar Two so
expensive it becomes the fourth or fifth
highest grossing film in history just to
break even interesting movies are out
man movies are out or theater movies are
you are you even excited for this no I
don't care the first one kind of sucked
up hey look visually it's stunning
beautiful but like out of the gate it's
like in the future and you see this guy
on like a manual wheelchair I'm like you
can't get a [ __ ] futuristic wheelie
yeah yeah yeah like I'm like this out of
the gate I was like I'm out Stephen
Hawking even had a thing with a scooter
you know he had a motor on his even can
you imagine spending two billion dollars
on this film billion that's two thousand
million dollars wow
Biden will send that money to Ukraine
[Music]
this is not what listen the last few
weeks without Sal I'm sorry that hey
babes went a little bit off the rails
but this is the real me
what's up everybody got a brand new hour
of stand-up material December 15th we're
in Charlotte December 16th Asheville
December 17th Charleston South Carolina
December 31st Huntington New York at the
Paramount for New Year's Eve January
12th New Orleans January 13th Dallas
January 14th Houston Texas
christycomedy.com for Ticket Wiki's
brand new hour material I'm gonna wear
this [ __ ] box on my head and I'm
gonna eat somebody's
boxing it's a sound of Shopify
it's the sound of Shopify listen with
Shopify you'll create an online store in
your Vibe discover new customers and
grow and grow the following that keeps
them coming back Shopify is a must if
you're a business owner 24 7 support
free libraries full of educational
content Shopify has got you every step
of the way we were using it here for a
while we're still using it that's how we
get the merch out Shopify thank you it's
how every minute new sellers around the
world will make their first sale with
Shopify and you will too
Shopify is dope
um they literally just make it so simple
to get all your products out to the
people
um when you're ready to launch your
thing into the spotlight do it with
Shopify the Commerce platform backing
millions of businesses down the street
and around the globe
right now you can get a sweet discount
if you sign up for a free trial at
shopify.com hey babe go to shopify.com
hey babe to start selling online today
that's shopify.com hey babe
rocket money you have to check out
rocket money they will help you manage
and cancel subscriptions you do not need
one or simply forgot about with just a
tap tap it up sound familiar that's
because you've heard me talk about my
favorite app true bill before but now
it's called Rocket money and I'm gonna
let you in a little secret true bill is
now backed by rocket companies and just
changed their name to Rocket money so
there you go we like it rocket money
bottom line rocket money is everything
I've Loved about true bill but with a
fresh look and feel right now you can
start canceling your unused
subscriptions and save money at
rocketmoney.com hey babe that's
rocketmoney.com hey babe go to
rocketmoney.com hey babe download the
app from the app store or Google Play
Store rocket money thank you you saved
my life the pistol that shot and killed
aren't Duke friends Ferdinand in 1914
sparking World War one that see here's
the thing that that
um Franz Ferdinand when he got shot in
World War one and it's caused like this
whole like World War to happen that [ __ ]
can happen now all it takes is one
little mistake one little mishap and
you're and we're kind of gonna go down
some the Japan prime minister did get
assassinated recently yeah
he got shot with a fake gun yeah we
talked about that a couple of months ago
but he's not the current prime minister
but he wasn't yeah he was it was like
it'd be like if oh you know [ __ ]
Clinton or Obama or somebody got shot
the current okay but still it's like he
was like a national hero what do you
mean a fake gun like the guy who tried
to attack no like in fact the guy was a
homemade gun like it wasn't a gun like
that it was like a homemade able to
explode it was like an explosion yeah
make homemade guns hit him in the
sternum yeah Japan versus Germany World
Cup uh tomorrow who do you got which one
who do you got yeah yeah I guess you
know I gotta go Japan yeah yeah you got
to gotta go Japan yeah it's uh
interesting I um what is this sells
methods yeah you can get meth anywhere
now Amazon's selling meth pipes wow
do not do cocaine kids if you're home do
not do cocaine it is literally it's all
laced with fentanyl and I'm not talking
about like if you're out also not just
if you're home if you're out don't do
cocaine yes don't do Coke tell your mom
to shave her Beaver do you um you never
you guys do blow I've never done
the only drugs I've done is I've done
Edibles i've smoked weed and I kind of
want to get more into edibles but I I um
shrooms you would love shrooms you've
done shrooms many times I think about my
wedding yeah and everyone's passed them
around his wedding I don't I don't you
don't do any type of drugs like that I
like I like uh drugs that push
everything down but doesn't mushrooms do
that fentanyl does that yeah there you
go now way
um I I was in I had a show in Toronto
and I ate an edible on stage a half I've
never done this I just took a bite in
the last show I took a bite of a of an
edible half of it and then I said who
wants this in the front row and I gave
it to some kid and he he ate it and then
we're doing a little crowd work 20
minutes later found out he's recovering
heroin I was like one guy in this place
well he accepted it he accepted anything
he wrote on he wrote on the patreon he
was like thanks so much I feel great I'm
back to heroin
I'm living in a dumpster but I've got 5G
for another week yeah yeah but but it
was great I um yeah man smokes uh
Chinese Marathon or smokes opponents
with three and a half hour time oh while
ripping darts smoking cigarettes dudes
writing these headlines
some kid in Brooklyn TMZ homeless pimp
he's smoking darts he rips through he
smokes stogie yeah look at this guy I
mean bad ass honestly it is good for him
don't tell us about it we don't care
we're all sick of it it's also like
it's just just pick a [ __ ] team like
it's weird to be smoking cigarettes and
do that just pick a lifestyle right yeah
what do you want to be healthy or not
healthy right right I um straight vegan
today I went to this book it's like when
you see a guy at the bar reading I'm
like [ __ ] yeah that book out of here
right make some bad decisions like the
rest of us yeah unless you're reading
like [ __ ] 101 yeah it's one of one of
my favorite books It's a Wonderful book
yeah it's the sequel that Brendan shaves
or beaver
I um I I went to the doctor today and I
went in there and um and my blood
pressure it it always is so high the
first time like like like because you
know I get so nervous it's so high and
the [ __ ] doctor knew who I was was
like oh I gotta ask are you and I you
know Chris and I said yeah and they were
like wow and then um so I got my blood
pressure you know so high and then she
was like uh really yeah she it was high
and then I was like I was like I promise
you like if you just give me like 10
minutes It'll come down and she's like
okay she started talking 15 minutes
later it's getting even higher even
higher even higher and then she was just
like literally at the end of it she was
like I know you guys have like a lot of
fun on the podcast I love your show she
was like but these numbers indicate that
you're using drugs are you using drugs I
swear to God and I was like no I'm not
that's how high your anxiety that's what
I said I was like I was like if you
listen to the Pod you know like I stress
myself out and she was like well you
know uh if you're using cocaine you need
to you should just tell me and I was
like I'm not using I'm not using cocaine
at all and then I asked her about
psychedelics I was like you know
Ayahuasca or anything like that and
she's like I don't want to do what I was
well no well she said she was like I'm
not you know as a as your clinician I
should say don't experiment with any of
those drugs she's like but the latest
evidence does show that all these types
of psychedelics and psilocybins are
proven to lower anxiety and blood
pressure
that's the one that seems like it's like
you're like vomiting for hours and [ __ ]
that seems rough you need to show them
in you have to go to like Peru dude I I
did uh I did the comics come home show
last week um and they do it at like you
know TD Garden I went up dude it was
funny I went up I I went up right before
Fallon so I was like I was like this
would be good like you know like have a
good set whatever dude I literally made
that mistake because it's tough to do
10-minute sets I did I made that mistake
where I saw that I got the light at nine
minutes I was like let me cram a two and
a half minute into a minute and I just
missed like three punch lines kind of
[ __ ] bombed in front of the last bit
kind of didn't do well in front of 18
000 people and I was like ah Jimmy I was
like I was like I I was like did you
just get in here now he's like I watched
you from the first second
and then uh he didn't give a [ __ ] though
he just went up there and started just
doing you're just doing a Brenda grocery
Beaver material yeah yeah okay you guys
haven't heard of this book Jimmy Fallon
wrote a book called Dad my daughter I
used to read it to my daughter I used to
read it to my daughter when she was a
baby yeah Kimmel wrote a book too every
all of them are the duck yeah
you know oh yeah Gordon wrote a book
called uh how to get kicked out of
restaurants yeah yeah [ __ ] these egg
whites dude I would never by the way I
would never in a million years ever
complain about my food
I've never said anything back how crazy
do you have to be to literally complain
to a wait wait you know the problem is
his Persona is like the nice guy that's
what it is right it's like if Anthony
jeselnick just like Smiles at you you're
like what a wonderful man yeah but if
Gordon is not a hundred percent the most
biggest teddy bear you've ever met right
dude my girl used to work in a movie
theater when she was 15 16 years old in
in Bay Ridge that if you pissed him off
they were piss in the popcorn oh you
would if you lived in Bay Ridge in the
late 90s and you pissed off any of the
Puerto Rican staff members the Alpine
Cinema you got urine in your popcorn
just know that I think you know when the
box was wet you probably you threw up
you threw up for the next week like
you're on ayahuasca
I um you're right though it's it's what
it's the same with Ellen like she acts
all nice and then when she's mean to the
staff you know that's why if Ray Rice
doesn't hit you you're like it's a good
day good day yeah he [ __ ] really
clocked out lady oh it was quite a smack
but they're still together no I think so
well that relationship's had a lot of
ups and downs
there it is
sometimes so many levels sometimes love
smacks in the face push the buttons look
yeah so you see Ray Ray Rice's wife yep
wow
um yeah well he's out of the NFL now but
it's tough black women are more
supportive than white women they will
stand by you do a lot of [ __ ] they're
just more supportive in general Cosby's
wife is still
case in point okay send Point yeah well
shout out Bill Cosby all right get him
on the show he'll be co-hosting hey babe
next week if Sal doesn't return
it's a holiday episode that's what it is
I wonder how many of the hey babe fans
have shut this pod off in the in the
first five minutes because this is
wholesome no cursing this is like you
know and we have just but you know what
[ __ ] me this is a new regime [ __ ]
I'm treating this this podcast is the
new Qatar
Cosby does hate woke people yeah you
think it Cosby Thanksgiving everyone's
like is it the turkey that's making this
time
yeah it's like a strepto fan
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] dude how funny was
that first tweet Yesterday by Kanye
tweeted Shalom uh oh it came out of the
game I saw I saw Jess Curson responded
Lexapro I like that I hearted that Jew
Jess Kirsten Jess Kirsten is I I
literally so I've been off I'm gonna
talk about it but I've been off social
media for months but what I do is I have
a uh Instagram for like my um my kids
just like a private one and I follow
Jessica Kirsten on it because Jazz it's
like has always been like such a big big
fan her comedy like I now see like where
it's like she just makes me happy
there's times when like you're feeling
down and dumps I'm like I'm just [ __ ]
laughing at this woman you know and uh
and yeah so shout out Jessica Kirsten
yeah are you guys going to do my vice
show both of you guys are on though can
you do a show in [ __ ] Manhattan
why why are you trying to book us on a
show in Stamford Connecticut I told
Emilio and I told Vice nobody's gonna
come do it in in Stamford Connecticut
and they're like no it'll we'll send
them a car service I was like they don't
give a [ __ ] it takes two hours a full
day I know that's what I said I said but
I did get Hassan Minaj because he lives
close by well okay yeah I got Hassan I
got people that are like live up I got
Jerry Springer all of it just coming on
wow no no you'll get me a pharaoh yeah I
I literally I'm hosting the show for
vice we're gonna start filming in a
couple weeks and I literally 95 of the
people I've asked have said no and they
cite the same reason they're like love
you buddy this is how it started my
publicist called me and she said Chris
and Stephanie wants his new show I said
anything for Chris and she goes let me
finish it's in Stanford Connecticut I
said Chris can go [ __ ] himself yeah yeah
what if I what if I give you if I
promise you get a hot coffee with almond
milk oh oat milk sorry I forgot yeah
you're allergic I said yes to the gig
then he called me goes you're doing this
it's in Connecticut and I said hold on
let me call my agent I was just like I
mean maybe if Mark's doing them like
maybe we split a cardboard I was like I
can't spend a whole [ __ ] day I'm on
the road every week no I know because it
would be like a whole day dude the whole
day the whole day because at first why
can't you just film it in New York if I
had any control at all I would film it
on Staten Island I need to join the
[ __ ] Sports Center crew while you're
out there Bristol well that's what I
said I was like all I want to do is you
know I'm willing to do TV but I want to
do it from home and they're like my
agent's like 100 we got you the show
films you're gonna be home and I was
like great so I'm like he's like East
Coast baby so I was like amazing
he goes Northeast baby yeah and I was no
no no no
um um uh who was it my person the other
Katie uh Northeast he goes Northeast
baby I was like great and uh and then
she was like but you know it's in
Stanford Connecticut I was like hold on
I was like do you realize that's two
hours away from uh Staten Island she
goes oh it's an hour and 45 minutes oh
they always do that I was like So What
by the way vanity how long were we in an
Uber back to Manhattan from Christmas
that Island place two and a half hours
maybe three I was like oh my God thank
God she's cool dude dude I literally I
literally uh [ __ ] I was like I'm
gonna have to just get an Airbnb and
stay up there yeah I I want my whole
point of doing TV was like I wanna I
wanna be able to sleep you know my house
each night yes my brother was in Sandy
Hook I'd even go to that really no I'm
joking I'm just saying it's Connecticut
you believe that yeah I would have heard
about that
I would have had 10 minutes on it oh
great
yeah you would have put hey the San
Diego materials only on the patreon yeah
yeah dude so yeah actually you guys are
gonna do the show well maybe if we get a
second season it moves to New York
you'll do it that's the plan all right
I'm in but well we got Jessica Kirsten
now she said oh I think she lives up
there too Canon got my Cannon doing it
all right well it's really dropping
Schultz is gonna
Schultz said he do it okay
does he know what's in Connecticut no
we're sending him an Uber helicopter
he gets a blade yeah yeah what have I
got you guys Blaze now I'm in yeah you
do not want to get in a helicopter well
I love Kobe all right that was it that
was the one that's it what else check
out a special Jew on YouTube
baby the NFL is back I'm so pumped and
that means DraftKings DraftKings
DraftKings check this out right now
everyone right now go download
DraftKings you can earn up to a 100
boost with DraftKings stepped up same
gay parlays go to the DraftKings
Sportsbook app place the same game
parlay and combine multiple bets like
which team will win player props Point
totals and more right now new customers
can bet just five dollars on any any NFL
team to win their game and get 150 in
free bets if they do download the
DraftKings Sportsbook app right now use
code hey babe place a five dollar bet on
any NFL team to win their game and get
150 in free bets if they do
only at DraftKings Sportsbook with code
hey babe minimum age and uh eligibility
restrictions applying see show notes for
details thank you DraftKings right now a
word from our sponsor better help better
help you know uh I talk about it every
week I love it shout out to my therapist
who's been helping me
for the last few months with better help
um they told me that wearing a cardboard
box in my head will help keep me safe
and so far it has been better help it
literally it helps you find your own
Solutions
there's no better feeling
a therapist can help you become a better
problem solver making easy to accomplish
your goals no matter how big or small
now
I'm choking because I love better hop so
much
I'm breathing in something
when you want
to be a better Problem Solver therapy
can get you there visit betterhealth.com
hey babe today to get 10 off your first
month that's better help.com
slash hey babe thank you better help you
really saved my life
[Music]
well I just read the Jewish version of
Brenda shaves or Beaver it's called a
Brenda won't shaver Beaver it's called
yeah Brenda's Bush
only fan star Courtney clenny big
hooters raked in three million dollars
from sight before killing boyfriend I
mean yeah they only she killed her
boyfriend by the way there's they're
trying to the media was trying to make
it seem like they were arguing he was
abusive she stabbed her boyfriend in the
shoulder
yeah that I would like to see yeah why
did she why did she they got into a
fight she was like uh you know they were
they were like a domestic dispute right
I've seen a few of these only fan girls
be very violent really yeah I think it
kind of that lends itself to maybe just
popping off having a short fuse Don't Go
Near Karen feon
oh maybe it's you know part of being an
entrepreneur you know you do it yourself
you're busy yeah I mean I mean oh by the
way yeah Ice Cube confirms he lost nine
million dollars uh uh after refusing to
get the covet shot [ __ ] y'all for trying
to make me get it ice cube I understand
you lose some money but just get a fake
I mean all you have to do you do you
don't have to be honest about this
anymore right if somebody forces you to
do it you can just get a fake and if you
want to get that fake go to Nino's
Pizzeria on Third Avenue he knows it's
good pizza if you order two slices in
The Garlic Knot they they know what they
know what it means oh that's good sauce
on the side
and 250 cash he got me my prenup
did you sign one did you sign a preenie
oh yeah you have to right really is it a
point no but is it I'm going to ask is
it a point is it when you sign a prenup
with it is it like just one of those
things where it's like hey with type of
career you got you got to do it or was
there like a little bit of like oh that
was friction but I know it's like hey
she's a great gal I love her whatever
but like getting married is not my I did
that for her so I'm like well do this
for me this is part of the vows too it's
pretty good yeah
Mark anything is like look I love you
but I didn't want this I didn't yeah did
you get uh do you got you guys want kids
yeah yeah but you're gonna wait up what
are you doing I wait a little bit well
you know you can freeze eggs uh you can
do technology now
I sometimes is she on the pill she's on
the Nouveau
and you get the little prick I get a
little prick on the e-hole yeah do you
don't love that uh don't love that
little prick it happens no no no
did Peter make it to the wedding no he's
got a new kid oh he's got a new baby
yeah he didn't pull out Jesus Christ
Vita Vita looks like an embryo yeah
pull up pictures of Gary veter let's see
ask the fans of either Gary Peter I
think he's got embryo face no he's got
uh he looks like Professor
[ __ ] embryo look at this kid he does
look look at it looks like an embryo oh
my God you just put glasses on one of
your girls look how cute he is with
Michael Jordan adorable oh look at that
Herschel Walker
I like that hair man he's got like a
Japanese haircut that was the 90s bowl
that was the Dumb and Dumber and his dad
his dad's in uh was in prison for a
little bit right that's right yeah I
like that yeah you don't expect that you
don't expect this kid uh to have a
[ __ ] criminal down but we should
interview him his dad is white I'd love
to interview his dad TT Jerry interview
his dad he has like a full NPR series
coming out about it oh wow I think it's
I Heart Radio yeah but it's coming out
soon the story is incredible no Gary
Peter if you don't know Gary veter which
you should Gary veter
um uh he's um one of those he's a great
comic Killer Joke writer Killer Joke
writer and uh I'm yeah he would have
been one of Jeffrey Dahmer's victims
honey lived in Milwaukee
um the one with with John Elway down
there look at that [ __ ] whoa wow that
looks like a Make-a-Wish situation
[Music]
Jesus
Illustrated for kids and that which like
it was kind of like so he would show up
as like The Chaperone and they would
just get like they'd be like game seven
you know for whatever faulted Gary's
father for that I thought he was trying
to do what he want you know he's trying
to give his kid a good life I mean it's
it's it's other areas yeah it wasn't
just the game I think he was a maybe a
fake veteran allegedly there was a lot
of [ __ ] yeah there was a lot there was a
lot of [ __ ] going on yeah he wasn't
father of the year let's put it that way
yeah he was a reporter of the year yeah
he was like Gary you already look like
you kind of you kind of have pediatric
cancer so we're going to start to get
you into some hospitals to meet the
players get some donations so just a
little bit just a little bit of makeup
under the eyes
um well look at how fat this [ __ ]
fish is oh geez there it is Jesus Christ
fisherman lands walking people just
holding these things it's disgusting I
would never well like I was watching
Yellowstone yesterday and even though
like it's a show that they had to
they're like there were these wolves
that got killed and they had to take the
collars off the Wolves I'm like gpsing
and I'm like I would never be able to
touch a dead animal like I couldn't even
pick it up it's so creepy I don't like
it I know but those are like country
folks we're City kids we don't do that
yeah we don't do it yeah dude
Yellowstone by the way you watch
Yellowstone it's fun great show how do
you watch the new season dude I haven't
seen that yet the new Season's like I
don't know where to find it it's on Hulu
oh well I go to Hulu and then just put
in the search engine Yellowstone and
Pops I do it like an old man I sell
cable I don't have to do any of this
Paramount plus that's what it's on
Yellowstone yeah but it's not so is our
Comedy Central hour specials and half
hours
[Laughter]
Yellowstone is like Republican porn
the white guy was like I'm not gonna let
these Native Americans take my land I'm
like hell yeah oh yeah it's succession
for conservatives they never they never
say what political party he's in but you
know oh no he's a republican do they say
it ever outright I don't know but he's
but it's like dude the show is so fun
the guy the best characters that guy rip
yeah I love reps you know what's great
about that actor rip he was he was Vince
Vaughn's brother in the movie The
Breakup so he's like a good comedic
actor too yeah wait pull that up yeah
pull up rip uh I don't know what his
name his name is the woman he's with is
[ __ ] oh my Irish chick
yeah she's British oh is that right yeah
yeah there it is no not not Wedding
Crashers are the breakup no no uh with
with Jennifer Aniston yeah see see uh
what's his real name
yeah yeah wow bad wingman
Cole Hauser yeah he was [ __ ] he was
he was uh as soon as I saw him I was
like that's the brother from is that him
from Vince that's the other brother from
uh the breakup great there he looks like
if Bert Kreischer never drank
there it is what did you guys think of
Dahmer I enjoyed it I didn't watch it I
like it for me I couldn't get into it I
gotta be honest for me now even though I
wear consumers like the glorifying of
serial killers I'm like I thought you
love it he's killing gays yeah yeah no I
know that's a genre he doesn't like
serial killer he likes gay murder yeah
yeah no dude you know I like uh I I'm
I'm done with uh true it's true crime
it's too much you know what I like it
but they throw so much at you you're
like how much of this can I watch Once
they made the bodybuilding one with this
woman who like Killers Sammy or
something not everyone deserves Their
Own True Crime right yeah but you know
it's weird it's starting to feel like
podcast circuit well it's starting to
feel like it's true it's starting to
feel like it's starting to feel like I
bet you there's going to be people out
there it's like it'll get to the point
where like somebody made so much money
on a True Crime documentary that they'll
commit a crime themselves to [ __ ]
mate just so they can get the material
like yeah eventually you run out of
material like these kids that were
killed in Idaho University of Idaho four
kids four kids murdered with a knife
they have no idea where the knife is
they have no idea the murder is I
already thought I was like somebody's
gonna make it somebody is writing that
script right now it's in development
immediately but I look at True Crime now
the way I look at stand-up specials I'm
like this [ __ ] jerk off yeah
everybody has a true crime now yeah
everyone everyone Ted Bundy John Gacy
who's big one we're missing who's a good
True Crime though Ted Bundy one was good
I thought Casey Anthony will be a big
one oh they've done it I think but when
they did it already some of them like
you know you're it's like stand up where
you get bombed you're like did we get it
you're like but it's on peacock yeah you
know it's like you're not gonna hit the
eyeballs we wanted yeah but Hey listen
they're the only ones I want to buy so
in case you can kill another one of your
kids and maybe we can try to pitch that
to HBO Max that's something dude yeah
she's cute she is yeah we don't was she
blue or lawyer too right that lawyer
lawyer yeah her lawyer was like I can
get him paid and uh [ __ ] get out of
here oh there you go Jose Baez
I unequivocally and categorically deny
exchanging sex for my legal services
with Miss Anthony I further
unequivocally and categorically deny
having any sexual relationship with Miss
Anthony so you [ __ ] Miss Anthony does
she do does he use lawyer talk while
she's blowing him I'm gonna work the
ball he's like I'll let it
[Music]
goes sustained yeah can I put a finger
in the butt objection
wow it didn't happen with Johnny Depp
too Johnny Depp banged his lawyer uh
they went on a few dates oh for real did
they yeah I thought that was rumors huh
Latina she's pretty yeah very pretty but
is that now not a power power Dynamic
thing you think
it depends yeah now where she's also
it's got like a hero thing I mean she's
helping us yeah big fan I mean there's
certain you put people on a pedestal
right if you're in class something about
the teacher certain settings you know a
bartender gets lifted up right
yeah I guess a lawyer is Defending Your
Case yeah well I mean dude even even
like you know like like if we're just if
we just want to talk about like hot
sexual situations gay sex in Qatar is
probably hot of course those guys
probably have a blast because if you get
caught you're gonna get beheaded it's
taboo I think that's also the
president's name yeah
the [ __ ] in like private like this is
the best
not bad about sex what is when it was
illegal for gays it must have been so
much sexy oh wow yeah yeah now it's kind
of like anybody can do it yeah it's like
I like podcasting we got too many we all
do it used to be cool when only a few of
us were doing them yeah this was like a
rare one I was actually pumped for oh no
dude me too oh no listen I'm gonna ride
we're riding this thing to the [ __ ]
Wheels fall off but make no mistake the
wheels are beginning to fall off they're
falling off Sal hasn't been here in two
months
um
Sal's missing yeah now back in the day
all the comics used to do stuff for
Thanksgiving together did you guys ever
have that or by the way Johnny Depp in
this picture literally looks like one of
my aunts
he literally like I'm gonna see this
woman in Thanksgiving on Thursday hey
aunt that has hepatitis you know who you
are
um Johnny Depp loves candles and makes a
sweet candies yeah yeah hates her
husband and her kids haven't talked to
her in three years yeah
um what were you saying I'm sorry yeah
what do comedians do for Thanksgiving is
there like anything I used to do that
when we were poor we would do like a
friend's giving all get together we
always lived here and I always been a
yeah I used to go to Boston that was
like my family thing with my
grandparents were alive what are you
doing this thing we know Mark's family
here Boston or India no in New York yes
that's nice single well no girlfriend
right no but you so so with the family
then yeah okay I kind of like that no
pressure no pressure to go to the
girlfriend's house no pressure no you
know no pressure at all I kind of like a
single Thanksgiving I'm going to my
family's house not Jasmine's family so I
have no pressure I just bring I just I
show up at the gang of Puerto Ricans and
we have a good time but I have to how
about this I have to go and what am I
gonna say it's my mother I have to go
from Staten Island Drive to Ridgewood
Queens which is going to take an hour
and a half pick up my mother drive then
all the way to Ridgewood New Jersey
which is going to take an hour and a
half have Thanksgiving then drive my
mother all the way back to Richmond drop
off and then drive all the way back to
Staten Island and I swear to God I said
to him I said Mom it's almost as bad as
doing your show in Stamford Connecticut
well I said it's true it's Stanford
might be worse don't worry shops is
going yeah
yeah
Hassan Menage will be there yeah not my
Thanksgiving
he's doing a gigging guitar
so so I uh and I said to my mom I said
Mom what if instead all that I'll get
you like a real like not an Uber I'm
talking about I'll call like I'll get
you like a black SUV beautiful car
seated Heats I'll pay for the whole
thing round trip nothing and her she
wrote back I'm not one of your [ __ ] oh
oh you treat your horse well yeah I know
I know I was like you wish
[Laughter]
yeah yeah I gotta ride with my other
horse yeah
yeah dude so like I'm gonna be in the
car for like five hours with [ __ ]
three kids and an angry one you said
it's not a stressful day that's a very
high it is it is it's gonna be brutal
but that's what I think the plan is once
I drop once I get the family safe to New
Jersey popping edible I'm thinking of
popping Giants are playing too the
Giants are playing that's exciting oh
Jasmine's calling me hold on and I'm
sure hello let me watch it yeah probably
stuff that's classic hold on you're on
the Pod with Mark and Sam you have
anything to say
that was very fake we could tell the
high-pitched voice that was fake
not anymore
it was removed you got your fakes
removed
well I don't want to talk to her now
excuse me
what is for dinner
turkey
what's for dinner
well what do you well let me know and
then if you tell if it's something good
I'll come home if not I'm gonna eat
Mark's ass
oh that's good that was on speaker hey
baby
hi violet
how's your beaver I was telling them
about how dumb how Delilah reads that
look Brenda needs a beaver
or something yeah Brenda's Brenda's
Brenda's Beaver needs to shave her
Beaver yes
what do you think of that do you think
that do you think that there's uh sexual
undertones to that or that's just an
Anderson children's book did you read
the books he can't read yeah yes I read
the I've read I read it to my daughter
at night to put her to sleep
she loves that book right there is one
of her favorites oh she is yeah I know
she wants to play softball too
oh lesbian what can you do
um that's good when yeah
um how about tortellini
I don't have tortellini what this is
such a different life than I have yeah
this is crazy by the is Delilah home
you're like I'll get wings at the cellar
for dinner it's I'm headed after this
already this early huh I'm running an
hour 7 30. is Delilah home
how was basketball practice how was
basketball practice
she hates basketball don't Jesus don't
tell my dad that
Chris Works he has to do his catch-ups
on his [ __ ] podcast tell her tell her
literally she better start playing
basketball we're going to Qatar he's
gonna get content of the marriage
counseling
what is pimps in the corner yeah I'm
ready I'm ready hey guys I know guys I
know I'm having a therapy session right
now but if you really want a real
therapy go to betterhelp.com promo code
um Kanye is the new sponsor all right
Jazz I'll talk to you later it would be
a great partnership
hey wait what happened I've been doing
that on Kanye better help okay okay
that'd be [ __ ] awesome yeah she's uh
that um so she I thought that because
anytime she calls me when she knows I'm
potting I thought it was going to be
emergency but there's no emergency she
just wants to know what I want for
dinner I'm telling you since she got her
boobs removed she's a different person
yeah I do pay for that yeah exactly
that's why I added shelves in Calgary
um
yeah you're gonna freeze to death and
you don't get bigger tits I think this
is great
for smaller tits but she literally it's
it's like it's like dealing with a
different person she's in a better mood
oh she's amazing she's a better
personality she's she's happy all the
time yeah holy [ __ ] she's happy she's
happy all the time everything's all is
it in pain or was she she just hated
that she had them in her body she hated
that she like she kept saying like I
feel like I morphed my body and I don't
want our girls to I don't want our girls
to think this is okay so I want to get
so she got fake tits and then she got
the fake tits taken out exactly yeah she
got the fake tits like 10 years ago and
then she got them taken out for you
what you mean I didn't know her when she
got the fakes oh okay but I knew him I
paid for him to get him out but now she
but then she got Botox in her lips so
I'm like what are you doing oh that's
not fair yeah
well Botox if you just follow Instagram
you know yeah I follow I didn't punch
her that's with the [ __ ] Botox oh my
God I had to go bite my lip during sex I
hate that that I was like could you not
please never do that who are you [ __ ]
Marv Albert
yes
half the audience is like who's that
more about look if you don't you should
know marvel you should know marvel but
you should Google Marv Albert that
joke's from like 1995. I know I like I I
just I brought that that's like one of
my dad's jokes I almost did Mike Tyson
so yeah
so she bit your lip and then
basically it was like inflated I was
like what the [ __ ] Jesus look don't ever
do that again and she goes okay okay
well I'm inside her does it again I was
like you really gotta stop doing that
I'm not into that like you you actually
have to stop the sex yeah and be like
the third time she did it I went soft I
was like what the [ __ ] oh really yeah
that's a song what is her problem I said
you know if I did this to you my career
would be over exactly yes yeah here here
seriously but and what how long ago was
that last night
[Laughter]
does she want to do the vice show
I might bite the driver on the way up
yeah oh God I can't wait for this
[ __ ] thing what can you do
um yeah turkey inflation what is it the
price of turkey's risen 21 oh yeah
Turkey um numbers are going up I don't
know though dude I I'm telling you man
we need the mob back we need Capone
giving out turkeys when the mafia was
safe with the mob I will say that now
that there's no organized
there's a couple groups of work this is
a great stance the mob really made
everyone say yeah right yeah throwing an
innocent man through a plate glass
window listen yeah as long as you didn't
[ __ ] with them the safest I ever [ __ ]
with they [ __ ] with people dude no the
safest you'd ever feel is when I was a
little kid I would go to uh uh the
carnival in Howard Beach on Crossbay
Boulevard and John Gotti and like his
guys would hand out uh cotton candy and
old candy to the kids and literally you
felt like no no don't worry about it
nope no you can run around no one's
gonna get abducted no kids are gonna get
raped nothing none of this shit's
happening with the goddies there but
you're in you're in with them now now a
week later they go hey remember that
cotton candy I got you I need you to go
kick that girl in the [ __ ] well there's
that story about about Joe Piscopo the
comedian Joe Pisco yeah one gig for the
mafia thought it was great loved it and
then they kept calling them every week
they're like 3 A.M on a Tuesday get up
here do different jokes exactly and then
and then he he did he just ran out of
material so I think he like freaked out
not freaked out or like just got mad one
night I teach and somebody broke his jaw
and they were laughing at him on the
floor with a broken jaw you know that's
where the word stand up comes from the
mob really yeah the guy this guy did
something like that he like [ __ ] up a
gig and he was like okay I'm out so they
went up to his hotel room slid his face
into a smile and left him there to bleed
out somebody saw the blood go under the
door they called the police he got saved
miraculously and he went back a year
later after he was healed and did
another gig for them and they go he's a
stand-up guy yeah that man became the
Joker from DC Comics
true story that's it look at that who
was the comic history Ralphie May
oh yeah all right yeah yeah what else
what else can you do I mean who gives a
[ __ ] yeah what are you guys doing for
the rest of the day
a couple spots over this dark out I'm
doing shows you got shows tonight yeah
seller seller seller stand just running
around running around baby baby well
it's Thanksgiving coming up the mom the
turkey the wife it's a lot so you gotta
you gotta get your sets it when you can
yeah I gotta [ __ ] go home I gotta
dude I I I I had TT Jerry you know runs
the you know it's like the the cleaning
lady and like The Nanny and like you
know run to house but she's been sick
the last couple days I haven't taken out
the garbage in two weeks I've just
forgotten about it's just piled up
behind my house so I have to go get the
[ __ ] garbage and bring it on because
Jasmine was like I'm not throwing out
that goddamn garbage that's a man's job
I was like you're the one with the
mustache and no tits
uh this would be a great sitcom you got
to pick up the garbage shut up
well a transgender persons
you can't even laugh track that's the
show that's the show mustache just just
Everybody Loves Raymond but you're a
[ __ ] monster yeah
sitting there with the energy of Ray
Romano's father just [ __ ] being a
dick yeah
I'm not one of your [ __ ] yeah
get in all right this is the out this is
the sitcom episode where can the people
find you what do we got on social yeah
social make sure make sure to get Bodega
again it is it's gonna be your favorite
ride even people who don't normally
drink rice they can't have it in Qatar
drink it yeah drink it for the qataris
bodega catwhiskey.com see us on the road
all at Sam Morel on all the socials uh
you know I'm everywhere coming up Kansas
City uh Fort Wayne Indiana this weekend
help numbers are low yeah
Kansas City uh [ __ ] Spokane Tacoma
and then theater tour starts I'm hitting
every city so it's samurai.com
everywhere Elliot I'll see you out there
hell yeah what about you Marky when does
this come out Thursday no I'm talking
about pimp
yeah
um let's see uh New Haven tickets are
low please come to the college music
hall or whatever it's called the big one
is it yeah yeah it's tough Fillmore uh
Fillmore and Philly uh yeah I just did
feel more in Philly how'd you like it
good hello but good okay Boston at the
Wilbur Buffalo Zanies in Nashville you
name it come on out Mark Noman comedy
and we might be drunk we don't forget
that's our podcast don't forget we might
be drunk boys thank you so much we
really appreciate it all right anything
else
uh no no just get rid of those tits
ladies Happy Thanksgiving Happy
Thanksgiving and see you in Stanford
all right sorry uh I love it man [ __ ]
pilgrims all right
Don't Be Afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe
[Music]